a simple reliable you pee one of the few
chimera ants who was not composed of any
human DNA whatsoever in fact GP was born
of a mixture of chimera ant and the
subscribe button for the new world
review which does explain the red
coloring and means that successfully
landing a hit on you pee will grant you
all regular hunt onto content uploaded
straight until YouTube feed no re I'm
sure it's not too difficult to smash
that you pee I mean maybe you know just
just let me know how you will grow with
that hello and welcome to the new order
vo source for everything anime and manga
and more specifically welcome to Hunter
hunter 101 the series that breaks down
everyone and everything in the Hunter
hunter world and today we are going to
be taking a gander at the youngest
member of the chimera and Royal Guard a
man who can be described as rage
incarnate men through the you pee men to
the you be who from here on out will
only be known as UB because that name is
just too painful to keep saying Thank
You Takashi is a demonic looking chimera
ant fellow who was created by the
original colony ant Queen in order to
serve the eventual king marijuana in
this effort you pee has the initial
distinction of actually being the only
member of the world God who despite his
human nish exterior did not inherit any
human DNA whatsoever rather you P was
born through a mix of chimera ant and
magical beasts genes and as a result of
that you P isn't constrained by all
those annoying human tendencies and he
comes across as the most simplistic and
instinctual of his contemporaries not
burned by unnecessary thought and always
focused on his particular goal making
you be initially completely selfless and
devoted entirely to the king without the
pesky emotions felt by Shia poof one if
a Peter for example however it should be
noted that the one prominent motion UB
was burned feeling was anger actually
you know what anger is a bit of an
understatement
I would go with fury or even all outrage
to describe that thing in which GP
engages in which is generally expressed
during combat these capacities made you
be an exceptional soldier though however
it did lead to a lot of difficulty when
interacting with the other Royal Guards
and even the king himself as he was
often confused by their various
eccentricities
not only that but newbies natural mental
capacities were even mocked by lesser
chimera ants such as well Finn who is
able to successfully extract information
from our crimson rural guard so you peez
not quite adept in the era of deception
will say but as previously stated you
peez true era of specialty was pure
combat and it would be put on full
display when maramures palace was
invaded by the extermination team just
prior to
the ants conducting the selection
process with the entire population of
East Quarter and as luck would have it
you pee will be the very first one to
encounter the bulk of their forces at
which point you pee simplicity became an
exceptional advantage as he ceased all
thought and began functioning as a very
primal being with but a single purpose
he was simply a shield to protect the
king now which point you P also grew a
ton of extra arms thanks to his natural
mastery of the art of nen and just in
terms of this you P is an enhancer which
is unsurprising because enhancers are
usually the punch now think later types
but as with all the world guards you P
also had a natural mastery of the other
classifications of known as well leading
him to develop a crazy series of hot sue
some of which are very difficult to
classify actually and one such example
would be metamorphosis which is the
aforementioned technique that allows you
P to spawn extra arms but it doesn't
client stop there as you P actually
appears to be capable of morphing his
body into whatever he wants really
for example after sprouting extra arms
you P then turned his arms into six
tentacle like structures in order to
attack relentlessly I might add at range
which would involve invoking other areas
than simple enhancement but UB has also
been shown capable of growing extra eyes
around his body and this one does in
order to effectively eliminate any blind
spots whilst engage in combat
furthermore you P can even transform
parts of his body into projectiles like
spikes and fire them at opponents and I
mean really there is theoretically no
limit to what you P can perform at his
power except for his aura I guess which
was estimated by a knuckle to be a
minimum of 700,000 units a truly
staggering amount which to put into some
context the Sehun tomorrow one of the
most superb their masters amongst the
hunter Association allegedly holds an
aura reserve of roughly 70,000 units so
UB is just casually sitting ten times
above that and therefore has a fair ton
of aura to play with right there and
these abilities were put to immediate
use against ups first primary opponent
to hunter by the name of chute however
despite shoot being a powerful hunter in
his own right and achieving a new
fountain state of enlightenment during
battle you P would go on to dispatch him
with great ease well you know what
actually that's probably giving you be
far too much credit really because
despite the incredible disparity in
general ability between the two across
the board you bee would grow
extraordinarily frustrated that he was
unable to win the conflict as swiftly as
his power would dictate he should but a
lot of that was due to a quite positive
ass
effective Abra or God which was simple
caution during the battle you P was
inflicted with a hit from shoots Hotel
Rafael SIA which replaced one of ups now
many many eyes with a black void and
whilst not inflicting any damage in and
of itself this greatly annoyed and
confused you P as well as made him very
very wary of the great unknown who
shoots abilities as a result of this you
P felt like he was completely unable to
let loose in combat seeing it as a
reckless endeavor that held a mild
chance of endangering not only him but
much more importantly the king rather
ironically not to derail the topic of
this video but shoot was the one in this
fight who began acting recklessly taking
advantage of you P says dents to really
go full force for the first time in his
life whilst you be adopted shoot small
timid persona for a brief period anyway
but this is something I'm personally
quite love about you P because it can be
very easy to dismiss him as a dumb
brawny power guy but there is a lot
going on behind the scenes in you P's
mind and he is a much more strategic
player in this ground game of life than
he often gets credit for and a similar
response was garnered from knuckles
hakurei because once you'd be noticed it
was attached to him this made him very
wary and also very angry very he very
angry Oh ever so angry which brings us
to another one of his Honsou known as a
rage blast whereby he engorges his body
with pure rage and unleashes it as an
incredible destructive explosion via the
wonderful realm of emissive net and
after engaging in this attack QP felt
great pleasure followed by a profound
sense of empty despair and it would be
at this moment where you p had a very
important moment of growth after
realizing the power that his fury holds
you P made a conscious decision to
control his rage rather than become
consumed by it all in order to better
serve the king and he would come to
master his fury quite quickly and even
channel it into a third Honsou dubbed
for aged incarnate and by channeling all
of his aggression which previously
resulted in an explosion
yupi was now able to transform his body
into a center like creature becoming
much faster which is already insane to
think about but more importantly he was
able to more efficiently wield his rage
in a precise and controlled manner
rather than simply letting it all loose
like an explosion it's kind of like the
initial basic principle of nen really
whereby the first step is to channel
one's aura in order to prevent it from
constantly escaping the body you'd be
learned to do exactly that just with the
substance of rage
rather than aura and with his collective
a power up1 taun to decimate everyone
who stood in his way
with the notable exception of kilowatt
whose godspeed ability was able to out
class you pee although kilowatt was
unable to use it to inflict any real
damage to the ever tanky Royal Guard
more importantly though these subsequent
fights against kilowatt Nicola Morel
brought about a new sensation of
selfishness with a new peak as he was
greatly enjoying the experience of
combat so much more that he even played
along with more smoke troops even after
he spotted morale himself and this was a
trait that yupi did not previously
possess as he lived only for the sake of
the King and dare I say it
yupi had now developed an intriguing Li
human quality selfishness is of course
paramount amongst humanity
what's more though is despite his utter
dominance UB also came to greatly
respect and admire the abilities of his
opponents even going so far as to call
them amazing however this did conflict
greatly with his designated mission as a
member of the Royal Guard as his chimera
ant nature urged yupi to kill his
opponents right then and there however
he had become somewhat enlightened
through facing their various known
abilities and was no longer able to
perceive the world from his prior
simplistic views having attained a true
level of intellectual evolution and he
then went on to engage in diplomacy in
which he struck a deal would knock all
to spare Mars life in exchange for NACO
removing her Kawara which was
threatening to very eventually render
you pee in a state of zetsu and after
this surprisingly peaceful resolution 12
this combat UB decided to depart sparing
all of their lives and even invited them
to challenge him once again claiming
that they would face off against each
other as equals oh and then he just grew
some wings because once again you began
do crazy stuff like that
however sad the U P would never receive
the chance to face off against the
humans he came to greatly admire because
after making his way to the king you'd
be found marijuana he put it a state of
disrepair following his battle with
Isaac Network and in order to revive him
yupi liquefied his cells and fed most of
his body to marrow M as did his fellow
Royal Guard Shia poof as a result the
king made a full recovery but UB was
left as a teeny tiny Chee BUP no longer
capable of wielding his once immense
power and very unfortunately he also
became infected with the secondary
effect of the poor man's rose the
explosive device that was activated upon
the death of nitro and after receiving a
lethal dose of said poison yupi would
suddenly pass away in the presence of
well Finn back at marijuana's Palace Us
ending the short and simple yet
incredible and somewhat inspiring life
of men to thievery some more fun facts
about you
be you peaceful name like all of the
rural gods is a combination of the name
of an Egyptian god as well as a
character from a French children's book
series which I always butcher due to my
lack of culture known as Carolyn let's
say a me and in this case mentor the
yupi comes from the God Montu and the
character of yupi prospectively you be
as with most chimera ants comes with a
fantastic rate statistics according to
the huntin manual scoring a perfect 5
out of 5 in the areas of skill partying
n throughout his tenure in the series
and very notably in the late stages of
the past invasion you peez mine Scott
went up to a perfect five and his
intelligence was even raised from a
three to a four although apparently his
ingenuity did suffer being reduced from
a four to A three while you P
shape-shifting abilities do not fit any
of the UH standard name classifications
an explanation for this might be the
fact that you P is part magical beasts
and is using inherited shape-shifting
power in combination with his
enhancement focused aura but having said
that there is a graded discussion to be
had here about what exactly magic will
be saw because hunter hunter is a world
that has become very strictly ruled by
the concept of aura and it's also
entirely possible that all magical
beasts are simply unconscious nen users
in which case we kind of land ourselves
back in the exact same position of not
really being able to explain most of
UPI's abilities I mean at best you could
probably make the argument that it is an
extreme form of enhancement and maybe
manipulation but it's on a fairly
unheard of scale for hunt hunter and
even then the prior examples of bodily
manipulation like say Biscay also fall
into an unexplained category as with
many characters in hunter hunter you P
does appear to draw inspiration from
other works in this case with mr.
Crimson and barring striking similarity
to the character of gato the main
antagonist of the parasite series the
very similar core abilities actually as
well as the aesthetic similarities and
finally a truly useless fact in Chapter
287 it was said that the amount of time
left before you people go bankrupt was
three minutes and 50 seconds whilst also
showing the amount of aura on Apr as
60,000 610 and because a PR compounds
are every 10 seconds you peez maximum
possible or remaining at this point in
the fight would be worked out by the
following equation which results in five
hundred forty two thousand seven hundred
and twenty units of aura however since
the narrator stated that you P had less
than 500,000 or
left then this would mean that the true
time was somewhat between 3 minutes and
40 seconds and 3 minutes and 50 seconds
yielding this equation as a much more
accurate guess which results in four
hundred ninety-three thousand three
hundred and eighty two units so more
precisely the time left before you P
would go bankrupt was around three
minutes and 41 seconds and that is quite
possibly the longest and most useless
fact I have ever stated in one of these
videos but that pretty much does it for
you P but what do you guys think please
to leave your thoughts in the comments
below or even join my discord server and
if you keen for some more hunt onto
content the please do go and check out
some of my other videos or even
subscribe to the channel a regular hunt
on to glory delivered straight until
YouTube feed but for now this has been
new old view and I'll see you next time
[Music]